hey Doug Walker here I just got done
seeing Halloween night 1963 in Hatton
vilela know there would be a cruise okay
so sibling whatever rate between kits in
the Myers family that's not mine that's
from do has been doing this I think
longer than me ie puts lyrics to movie
themes go check them out it's very funny
anyway I just saw a Halloween h2o one a
stupid title like all you I think that
title so stupid but someone got paid
like so much money to come up with that
title well we get caught and then just
dumber somebody had to agree to it just
like yeah yeah cuz it's not a reboot
it's a sequel boot so just call it the
original again cuz there's already two
movies and this franchise that have
their names just throw third and you've
heard that a million times
ok so most of you probably know but this
is a movie it's a rebooted sequel I
don't know how many of those there are
if there's any genre it's gonna have it
those gonna be horror and if there's any
series to have a deprived be Halloween
this is what happens now officially
after the first movie Jamie Lee Curtis
is back it's 40 years later and Mike
Myers again escapes and goes around
killing a bunch of teens only this time
Chloe wants revenge and she goes in and
tries to fight him as well and it's a
big epic battle between the two of them
for you know the last like 10 15 20
minutes but but it is there it is
definitely there so ok uh I had to come
at this movie just be 100% honest goofy
kind of popular opinion first Halloween
it's a very good movie it started a lot
of great stuff I mean if you're a horror
fan you gotta love Halloween it's almost
like law um
I don't get into it that much and never
got into the first Halloween I got into
the first ten minutes
and then everything else I felt like
well okay I've I've seen this in a
million movies and I try watching it
every year my wife loves the movie and
we always watch it and I just can't get
into it I don't really get into the
characters I think a lot of the killings
are kindest
and 'red I like a lot of the iconic
stuff like the music and the masks and
everything but the people don't interest
me and the killings don't interest me
I'm not a big slasher guy so you have to
know that going in I respect the hell
out of the movie but I don't really get
that into it
so with that said knowing that I feel
like people are gonna like this movie
people that like the first Halloween or
anyone that likes the Halloween series
at all will like this movie because it's
a lot of the same it's a lot of Michael
Myers sneaking around escaping going
after Laurie again I feel like they have
Laurie acting like kind of vengeful like
crazy angry she wants to get him before
I was saying they did that in h2o but
I'm not sure I never saw all of that
movie but but that's kind of a setup and
I was hoping that have more of an
interesting kind of angle without it's
kind of hoping a lot more interesting
ideas would happen in this because they
actually do set up some really cool
opportunities but it just comes back to
being the Halloween formula but people
who love slasher films they love that
formula and they love you know they have
those rules that you know whatever the
first film or the couple first couple
films set up and there's like you never
break those rules you never you have to
do ABC all the way to Z and beyond Z and
stuff like that go into Alpha Omega and
stuff like that different letters so if
so this movie is great for that and it's
not badly done it is very competently
done it's you know it got Jamie Lee
Curtis especially and it is a lot of fun
she's honestly the best thing is you
probably imagined she would be um even
before it gets to like you know the big
chase battle at the end I mean she's
just by far the best thing in this is
she runs a pretty good gamut of emotion
through and I really wish she was in it
more we do not to say you're not cheated
of her you don't feel like oh well they
were advertising jamie curott she's
barely and I know she is but
she's just the most interesting
character everyone else is either just
there to be killed very obviously or
they're passable um the the funny thing
about this movie is there's a lot of I
don't know if it's intentional comedy or
not it was getting laughs though in the
theater like that the two reporters that
start off this movie we're kind of
getting loud particularly the dude
because he was just kind of so over the
top and everything the father in this
the the father of the daughter I guess
the main character or one of the main
characters in this got some laughs and
it's like I think it's intentional that
there's a little boy that one of the
girls is babysitting that is really
funny and really cute and stuff so I
feel like those scenes that there's a
little bit of comedy which I like and
maybe I guess compare the first time we
may be a bit more personality but but
not much I mean that's always the thing
they set these characters just so they
can die and sometimes they die in a
funny way but it's almost never a
creative way it's still the knife it's
still just slamming someone's head
against something like I I guess for me
when I get into slasher film I want just
crazy out there insane I just want
to be so over the top there's a film on
Netflix called Tara fire that people
either love or hate and I love and I
know why people hate it cuz it is so
over-the-top extreme crazy it like
change make characters halfway through
and then introduce other random
character then kill them off and bring
others back and they just get be able to
craziest ways pretty much a killer mind
I'm sorry this is a review for Tara fire
now just see that movie but that's the
kind of slasher film I like I like the
one that really pushes the envelope
really does crazy and says see
let's see how far we can push this let's
see how just really big we can make it
while still sort of having a discipline
to you know it and even to some rules
you know as some rules that the slasher
genre kind of makes uh but Halloween at
least this one the first couple
exception of three obviously um it's
like they have to stick to that very
very straight formula and I thought the
parts where I was getting interesting
is there's the I want to say Jamie Lee
Curtis even calls him the new Loomis in
this but she my said you knew Loomis but
I swear she said you're the new Loomis
when this guy shows up cuz he's like the
guy who was taking care of Mike Meyers
and stuff and was analyzing him studied
under Loomis so now he's gonna be like
the British guy who goes and tries to
track him down and stuff but there's a
kind of a twist that happens with him
halfway through and I was really hoping
that was gonna lead to something it was
kind of playing around with the idea of
like the celebrity and the understanding
and the and the psychology the
fascination of serial killers and serial
killer monsters and stuff like that and
kind of how far you'll go for that
fascination and I was liking that and
then it just stops they just abandon it
um there's I feel like a lot of stuff is
kind of abandoned in this movie like
there's the cute little kid I was
talking about with the babysitter he's
really funny and everybody's laughing
out there loving this guy and he just
vanishes there's a boyfriend in this who
you find out you know that the main
character is going with this boy and
then you find out he's having an affair
or you're he's uh you know kiss I know
the girl and stuff like that and then he
vanishes like they sort of set up all
this stuff that kind of goes nowhere um
and I think the biggest one to me is
like I said the the idea of having Jamie
Lee Curtis come back you're gonna reboot
this whole movie series having Jamie Lee
Curtis come back just getting guns and
weapons or a whole house is home alone
proofed
and you know she's ready for this son of
a bitch and it's kind of all building up
to this and it leads to a decent climax
I and it like an appropriately
suspenseful climax where it's quiet it's
very slow but you kind of feel like
you're in the room with her like it's
the first legit suspenseful moment for
me in the movie because everything else
I'm like okay this is very
by-the-numbers but even then they sort
of this would be more clever if they
sort of did more with it they do a few
nods to the original like for example
you got the the make the
via granddaughter of glory and that's it
kind of I guess I kind of main character
in this and she's in her classroom and I
think they're even teaching the same
subject as in the first Halloween and
she and she sing in the back of the room
and everyone knows what's coming and she
looks out the window and there's Jamie
Lee Curtis looking at her it's like oh
that's interesting and then near the end
you know there there's a battle going I
don't think this isn't a spoiler but
obviously Mike Myers and Lori are gonna
fight in this and if she falls off a
roof at one point and he looks and he
hears somebody turns he looks back and
she's gone I just thought to myself now
why are they doing that I thought
wouldn't it be so cool if it was kind of
switched like the idea was we have so
idolized serial killer monster people in
movies and stuff that we actually almost
see them we do kind of see them as the
main character and then Lori's gonna
come in like she's the monster now
because she's gonna kill the character
we've all come to see that we've come to
root for and I thought would that be
fascinating but they don't do it they
don't do a thing with that it's just a
fight and it's one of those things where
I'm just thinking if you're gonna reboot
this series and that is what they're
doing I mean they don't have quite the
hand coming up he's still a live thing
but I mean they they don't show I'm
dying either and even if they did that
would meet but it does end kind of
abruptly and it's one of those things
where it's like you know well okay we
know another one can pop up because why
would they just do in their sequel
that's you know literally another sequel
another second movie got the third
second movie it's so weird
um and I really would like to see more
done with this more explored with this
but I also know there's a huge fan base
that just they kind of like seeing the
same movie over and over they like these
cliches they like I saw I saw some with
a real good crowd because the crowd is
constantly going don't go in there or oh
you dummy or what are you doing like
they're yelling at the screen which is a
zapper
movie you want that crowd for I always
stand by sometime you know a crowd does
not always have to be quiet like the
right crowd for the right movie this was
the right crowd for this movie you know
where every time someone's gonna do
something stupid and by Jesus everyone
this movie is a moron even Laurie makes
some dumbass mistakes in this but
everyone does the exact wrong thing runs
into the exact wrong room you know has
the exact wrong conversation with the
exact wrong person is taking the wrong
idiot for another idiot that gets them
killed so but there's a lot of people I
look forward to them but there's this
kind of comfort level strangely enough
and I kind of know this because I'm
gonna reference another movie here when
Sin City 2 came out I love this out
of that movie love it cuz I love that
world I love those characters I love
that I love all those stereotypes I love
those cliches there's something about
that world that I just kind of feel
comfortable in and everyone said well
hey it's way too late and B it's just a
repeat of like what the first film did
you know or there's not much different
it's just kind of the same old same old
and I know where they were coming from
but I was just like but that's that's
the fun of it I like returning back to
this world I like returning back to
these characters I like seeing them do
what they do and I know slasher films
are very much the same there is this
connection to them and there is this
strange comfort level that is strange
but but I understand it and I feel like
this film is gonna deliver that I don't
think it pushes the envelope you're not
gonna get something brand-new
mind-blowing or anything like that so do
not set yourself up for that at all
this is a movie that just once again
gives Mike Myers doing what he's doing
and giving you satisfactory climax with
a Jamie Lee Curtis at the end and it's
not just a fight it's kind of its how do
I put it's a slasher film fight where
there's a lot of creeping around there's
a lot of sneaking there's a lot of you
see over there is he over there and you
know is she gonna get is he gonna get
her you know and it's done well cuz you
like I say you really feel like you're
kind of in the
with her going through all this stuff so
that that's kind what I can say that the
people I had a few people afterwards it
was like it was a very social crowd and
the general feeling was it was okay
event that's kinda what everyone was
saying just like yes hmm
what I thought it was gonna be you're
just like yeah I don't know what else I
was expecting like everyone got what
they were expecting but I feel like they
wanted something they weren't expecting
you know the few surprises in here which
there are not many you know people got
into and I think they wanted to see more
and then when it never went anywhere
they're like oh okay whatever
so in my opinion it's just another
Halloween movie but I know so many
people that just want to see another
Halloween movie and I totally get that I
totally respect it so if that's kind of
my take on it in terms of like where'd
be like in the hierarchy of Halloween
movies I mean I guess the first
Halloween obviously I guess this one you
think about it and then honestly I
probably say the remake just guess it
was a little different than the other
second what cry had to be more specific
the first official sequel with Jamie Lee
Curtis and then probably Halloween 3 I
actually can't ever saw a spot for it
even I I don't think it's good but I I
like it
I can't bear my Barriss myself a little
bit - there's a scene where some
trick-or-treaters are going around
they're wearing the Halloween 3 masks
and I was the only one to laugh and I
laugh cow hard I just nobody else was
laughing I just shut out but I just
wanted turn say it's from Halloween 3 so
uh the one other funny thing I'll say is
that there's a like I said the the bits
of humor in this movie I really like and
they're very out of nowhere they're
usually with characters who do not last
very long they're in it for like a
minute
and the some of the characters are only
in this movie for a minute has the
funniest lines there's these two cops
they have a dumb conversation about
sandwich
it's so stupid I really made me laugh
and then there's another one with this
guy he's driving his son his little boy
and he's just he's talking about you
know I like hunting dad but I want to go
dancing I know what we'll do you really
get into their dance I do dad I do I
mean I like hunting with you it's fun
but I'm just dancing is really me right
now and like they're talking so serious
and this conversation just comes out of
nowhere and then you know suddenly it
kind of you see how they connect to the
story and it ties into Mike Myers escape
and these kids behind me they just said
the funniest thing as one girl just said
oh now you see if you just let them
dance what happened so yeah this is this
is another Halloween movie of dumb
people making dumb mistakes with you
know the same killer once again getting
that killing someone to get the suit
killing someone to get the mask and
going after glory again and the fight
between Lori and him like I says the is
kind of the highlight in my opinion but
it's not it's not like Freddy vs. Jason
where they're like rock music playing or
anything like that it's it's just a
suspenseful kind of cat-and-mouse chase
which is what it should be you know it
is still Halloween you know like that
makes sense to do so yeah that's about
it if you like the Halloween series if
you like slasher films I think this is
gonna give what you're expecting um I
it's not gonna go any further it's not
gonna jump any hurdles or anything I
would love if they did maybe that's why
I have a hot soft spot for Halloween
three because it did do something
different just 100% different um but but
I get it I think a lot of people I see
this movie are gonna enjoy seeing you
know those bullet points hit again that
there's enough humor that made it
interesting and like I say it was
building up to that nice little j /
fight at the end I do wish it was more
but I think that's because I just don't
get into these films that much so yeah
there it is go
tell me what you thought I'm actually
curious cuz it's because the critics
liked it I mean I think it's at like 70
90 percent or something like that Rotten
Tomatoes and I'm wondering if audiences
are liking it cuz the crowd I saw it
with they were like yeah that was okay
and some were even like yeah I didn't
like it but but nobody hated it I don't
remember anyone be like well that was
terrible that was BAE it's like it was
either yeah but those okay or in a kind
of like that so I'm wondering if I'm
wondering if this actually is like if
I'm missing something if there is
something like the brand and huge I just
totally totally missed it was like super
epic but for some reason because I don't
get into these movies I just completely
missed it so um let me know what you
think let me know if this is like is
this like a big game changer a big
ground breaker or is it just another
Halloween movie let me know and I will
talk to you later
take care
you